hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now I
went out and I got some fish hey Karen
I'm doing my intro here I love you baby
but you gotta let me be me it's not
gonna work out if you keep butting in
like that
sorry about that Karen can be a bit of
twos anyway so now I've got a whole
bunch of fish and I'm gonna put try to
put two of each of these in here
at a time and they're gonna have it whoa
he is not happy about where he is and
then one boomerang
okay so I got a bunch of fish in here
and I eventually imagined that when I
come back this bizarre creature egg is
just it's it's pulsating that creature
egg is pulsating it was not pulsating
before that is weird
oh that's weird but anyway I got a bunch
of fish in here and I'm gonna use the
planter on I guess I could put a creep
in there I've got some weird stuff like
I don't want to know what the floater is
but there's acid mushroom there's also
what's known as a deep shroom which is
like a rare thing that I found from way
way out of water so I'm gonna try to put
that in their aquarium here deep shroom
in there yeah there we go
oh they're pulsating too I'm so glad
everything in my alien aquarium is
pulsating so weirdly but that's okay I
guess okay so I give I can't believe I'm
so excited that I have an aquarium when
I'm in the middle of the ocean
like literally surrounded by all of
these fish but that's besides the point
I don't get to new species discovered
really but then in this way I get to
feel like I'm in control whereas
everything else I've done is absolutely
not in control and completely out of my
hands both in terms of Hemme dying and
everything trying to kill me both end up
me dying but you you get the point okay
so in this episode I'm going to fix up
my CMOS a little bit better because I
know it got banged up the last time but
then I am going to venture out and
explore a bit beyond where I have gone
before because I need to find the core
Pete obey Thank You Skype I'm not
interested right now haha okay so
apparently I look
up where to find the torpedo upgrade
people weren't very clear on where it
was or how it was it seemed like they
said it was already a part of this or
they were using calm like console
commands which is something that I don't
exactly want to do but either way so
what I have now is I have the ability to
get one more fret depth thing I've got a
computer chip despair because they just
scrapped my modification station and I
have plasteel because I have tons of
titanium and I've got lithium so I can
do that so I'm gonna I'm just craft this
up real quick BRB but I'm gonna get that
done
and Boop and boom goes the dynamite the
seamoth can now go down to 825 meters
below if I was feeling really ballsy I
would get all three of them in there but
frankly now let's do that let's do that
I want to all three of him there I want
to go as deep as deep as possible in
this game and I know that's gotta be
deep I know a thing or two about going
deep still doing okay in there
all right I'm trusting you on this I
want to look at the observation baby ooh
I can see nothing I picked a good view
but it's obscured by all the gunk and
and fish poop that's floating around in
the waters I wonder if I'm gonna see a
wild Sancho just like okay and pull this
out put this in and boom safe depth is
now 925 meters we can now go below a
thousand meters below the surface this
is really really cool
the duct is going to go where
we've never ever gone before I don't
even know how we're gonna get there but
we're gonna go for it so first I'm gonna
get out and repair Oh first I need to
get food for the road because I'm not
gonna survive if I'm stuck like this no
don't do that
Oh No but I put all the fish in the
aquarium I'll have to eat fishy fishy
fishy fishy fishy fishy in my inventory
oh that's pretty I didn't know I didn't
actually take a look at my base from now
out farmer after I built it I mean it
looks a little ramshackled and odd and
miss shapen but that's the way I like
things that's my type it's shaping and
odd okay so now I got ooh I got one more
hoop fish yeah I don't need it for now
I'm just gonna put that away cuz I am
almost set assault of all things I keep
running out of the most bizarre things
that I never think of getting so I got
two waters for the road and then to
cured items for the road so that student
doing good but the first thing I'm gonna
do is I need to get I need to get a new
knife because if I don't have a heated
blade I definitely need a blade period
because I need to cut things out of the
environment but I can eat some creepvine
I don't think worse is gonna come to
worse but I need okay so we got
everything we need for the road is
probably currently night and we're gonna
go in a direction that we have not
really gone before or been able to
explore and I think the deepest reaches
are back where I originally found like
the moon pool area kind of to the south
so I'm gonna go over that way and
explore that area because deep deep deep
deep down also to the west was another
area where the floating things were um
meanie meanie miney moe catch talk about
the toe
I will go to the south because I've
already been to the no I'll go Southwest
whatever make a compromise here let me
save before I do that who knows what
could happen in the darkness but we are
going to go on an adventure finally we
can go so deep down and this also means
that bumping into things won't do too
much damage until I get way way way
actually I think it'll probably still do
something so bye-bye bye-bye how see
hello on the wrong way bye-bye house
you be good shimmy shimmy I'll come back
to you eventually I'll find all the
exploded fragments of you some good god
I forgot that this ocean was populated
by horrible aliens it's not bump into
the rocks see on the other side oh we
found another entrance into this area
that's cool but I don't think I want to
follow it because I'm scared
oh gosh all right we already explored
this deep area so we're gonna go even
deeper because this is barely reaching
the the possibilities for this seem off
to go and this seamoth can go oh
Oh health down to 77 percent on that one
blast damn it
better better better better better whoa
wait is this always this oh that was the
exit to the ship that I found before
this is the place where I was I honestly
don't know if there was anything else
that I needed to explore in there seems
to be some sort of I'm gonna give it one
more go but if there's nothing
interesting that I'm just gonna head
back I got a knife no one wants to marry
ya nothing nothing
it didn't seem like there was a whole
lot going on there whoa what the Frick
what did that whoa what did that
okay got it got something I don't know
what I got I got it who don't like that
don't like it don't like it don't like
it okay good thing daylight come carry
me home off we go into the abyss again
oh boy oh boy oh boy here we go oh boy
here we go
oh crossing a million deaths oh there's
so much there's so much oh god I
shouldn't be I shouldn't be out here by
myself so much quartz though I want it I
want it all it's amazing that the like
me a simple human can take these
pressures possible cave opening down
there a thousand meters is that even
possible to reach how would you do that
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh I
think I've seen those before
oh we're going even deeper well we can
go so much deeper oh we can go so much
oh we've reached a new oh God horrifying
oh it even sounds terrifying what is
that is that something I can scan why is
it still on fire oh man whoa what are
you I have not seen you before
woah woah okay I'm gonna hop out for
just a hot second here okay that's not
scannable back in thank you Karen oh
we're out of here I don't know how to
get to that possible cave opening from
here but it seems way down there
it seemed wiki
way down there what is this Oh oh no I
don't even think if it was broad
daylight that the Sun would be able to
get down this far
actually I'm pretty sure it is broad
daylight and the Sun is not able to get
down as far that's exactly the reason I
don't see a way further deeper so I'm
gonna climb out of this plateau and I'm
going to try to find a way to navigate
safely out of here I'm gonna climb out
of here and then whoa oh oh did I reach
the edge of the map what is this oh my
god what is this what is this it's just
a sheer drop into nothing was I supposed
to go here oh this is not where I was
supposed to be Oh still going down Oh
still going down still nothing I'm
pretty sure this is just the edge of the
map and I was not supposed to be here
but just to test the limit I'm gonna go
down and I'm going to see what happens
when we get so far down that we yeah
this is this this is game-breaking yeah
I'm pretty sure this is perpetually
nothing oh that's so scary
oh it's so scary it literally is a sheer
drop into nothing there's nothing over
there oh boy what is this well I thought
that was quartz well it's so weird
Oh what is this luminescent algae let's
explore it grew cluster the hell is a
grew cluster I don't know what that is
oh sorry sorry sorry grew uh this it
does nothing it does nothing I'm just a
horrible person murdering these poor
plants or animals I don't know what they
are
they human so they don't matter
chicas not here whoa this is some weird
cave I just realized what could possibly
happen
I am I in an underwater cavern and could
this possibly be home to the giant
horrible monsters is that is that a
possibility that I'm approaching is that
entirely a possibility because I have a
funny feeling that I'm approaching
something that I shouldn't be
approaching oh crap damn it
another dead oh wait maybe not maybe not
maybe not this is the way I just came
it's getting a little confusing here
yeah okay
freedom I never want to go in there
again it confined spaces down so don't
know how to get to that but it may be
over here this is where I found the the
moonpool
plans and I was never able to go all the
way down to it so hopefully hopefully
some sorry fish why I am annihilating
what seemeth just by annihilating these
fish as their fault they got in my way
it's not my fault I'm not the
that's a weird rock formation almost as
if it was planned
this is also cool I mean I know this is
a fake world but I'd like feel like I'm
exploring something real and alive like
that's what that's what makes this game
so great is that it's so real it's so
real to me not in the way that like oh
it's virtual reality I can touch it no
it seems logical this seems honestly and
truly like an alien ocean and that just
maybe from ignorance on my understanding
of our ocean but frankly this terrifying
hello
oh god you freaky Spadefish this
terrifying terrifying terraformer fine
this is terrifying and awesome and just
so like it's just a situation of
curiosity killed the cat
I'm afraid to death to go down here and
I'm afraid of our own ocean but it's
just like oh there's so much oh there's
so much to see is this just yeah that's
the end of game end of game end of game
and I really do wonder like if I can get
down to that cave opening all the way
down there if there's some way that I
can do that there's gotta be some I'm
running out of energy though I may have
to dock back home I mean we did a good
bit of exploring and we saw a good bit
of crazy things
whoa okay big fans oh those are real in
our ocean - there's a lot of sea
creatures that live around those oh
that's cool this is what I mean this
place feels alive like the bottom of the
ocean is so cold and so much pressure
that it's very hard for life to exist
but there's volcanic vents down at the
bottom of the ocean that spew hot water
out and it's just a lot of creatures
live there just because it's warm
somewhere down where it's just crushing
pressure and ice cold because I mean
once you get down there it's like pretty
much all just frozen temperature water
like freezing temperature or below
because saltwater in the ocean has a
lower freezing point because there's so
many
it's so many things in the solution of
the ocean but man it's cool okay so my
next objective eventually where does
this go first let me see if this goes
okay so my next goal that I'll
accomplish in the next episode and I'm
gonna be doing a lot more in the next
episode that I have in this one is to
find the entrance to that cave opening
and then further expand my base and find
a way to confront the giant monster
hopefully kill it I want to be able to
kill that thing and then look for this
secret island so thank you everybody so
much for watching in the next episode
I'll name a few more names on my wall of
Heroes so thank you everybody so much
for watching thank you for all your
support click the annotations in the
district and stations up there or the
links in the description for more cool
videos that I've done there's a huge
array of playlist of videos that I've
done in the past thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you